le jour où j'ai fait pleurer mon
adversaire aux échecs ça se passe au fin
fond de la Serbie dans un tournoi pour
lequel j'été invité les conditions sont
désastreuses ma chambre d'hôtel les
draps sont troués étagés de s séché la
bouf est dégueulasse personne parle
anglais on est à la rond 5 pour
l'instant je perds plein de points hello
et en plus j'affronte un jeune serbe de
12 ans que là c'est 2000 mais qui a une
perf à plus de 2400 et qui a déjà battu
1 ETI et 1 m feed j'ai les pièces noires
je les croisé le matin dans le hall en
train de se préparer avec son entraîneur
donc je sens que je vais m'en prendre
une bonne sauf que devant les chiqué il
récite tout il est de Bill il a son
stylo dans une main et il joue avec
l'autre main mais il regarde pas du tout
ce qu'il fait vraiment en mode pas de
Blu je sais que j'ai une grosse prépa et
quand je joue B5 dans cette position
ultra thorique de l'espagnol il l'oublie
de recouler son fou incroyable il me
joue C TR là évidemment je le regarde je
regarde son fou je bouffe son fou là il
lève enfin les yeux je vois les larmes
qui commence à couler et moi je me
réjouis pas qu'il pleure et d'avoir une
victoire gratuite dans ce qui
s'annonçait un véritable guê à pon